it could be a little sunburn it could be
a little too big a little too small and
there's just a lot of produce that
doesn't make it to market there's
nothing wrong with this produce except
that it's ugly
most produce standards are grosser
chosen so they think that their
customers want to see produce that looks
like a perfect size a perfect shape
approximately 26% of produce in the US
gets rejected based on these
specifications the cosmetic standards
don't affect taste or nutrition at all
and those cosmetic standards are pretty
strict California pears for instance are
sorted in massive packing sheds each
pears examined for looks size and shape
the perfect looking pears are boxed and
shipped to retailers a pair with Nicks
and bruises will be sent to canneries
and juicers but then there is a fruit
that breaks the rules too big too small
or just goofy looking those pears are
tossed right in the trash when I see
pears that I've grown it makes me sad
that they got to throw it away nothing
wrong with it I mean it's got a mark on
it from rubbing the bark the mountains
of fruit that we waste is amazing every
year farmers throw away 6 billion pounds
of ugly or misshapen produce simply
because grocery stores won't buy it but
one businessman thinks consumers would
actually buy ugly food if they had the
choice it's up to us to put pressure on
the retailers and use all of the food
that farmers grow for us we're trying to
introduce this whole new concept to
American consumers Ron Clark co-founded
a startup called imperfect that sells
slightly flawed produce at a steep
discount the company buys produce that
would otherwise be
from farms I spent a many many years
walking orchards like this in
identifying sort of the sweet spot in
the distribution system where it's just
a little below market grade the way
above processor grade since July
the company has rescued 11,000 pounds of
California pears you wouldn't believe
the number of growers that are calling
us right now because there's such a
pent-up demand out there as far as
scalability this could just blow up we
are in a great California chain called
Raley's and we're doing a pilot program
with them at tender their stores they've
agreed to be the first major grocery
chain in America to feature this kind of
produce if American consumers embrace
this and then other chains start to pick
it up
I think the flood plates are going to
open